la drogue c'est thaïs et on sortir
parfois ou bien ça à chaque fois tu
essaies d'en sortir et surtout je ne
lâche pas demande sarthe hier je
replongeais et à un moment j'ai décidé
de m'en sortir je m'en suis sorti
comment tu as fait pour t'en sortir je
me suis dit à un moment qu'il fallait
que fallait que ça change je faisais 49
kg c'était il ya plus de dix ans de ça
c'était c'est pas maintenant et je
faisais 49 kg je mangeais plus je
dormais plus
ea et donc il ya un moment donné où on
se dit faut arrêter et et j'ai voulu
arrêter j'avoue vraiment que ça a été le
moment le plus pénible de ma vie aurait
alors cette descente aux enfers elle
n'en finit plus un moment tu vas penser
au pire
oui et en 2007 tu tombes de mettre fin à
ses jours en prenant trop de médicaments
oui qu'est-ce que tu t'es dit ce jour là
tu t'es dit je m'en sortirais jamais je
veux arrêter je suis franchement ça
tirait jamais j'ai voulu mourir donc on
regarde le soleil pour la dernière fois
on fait un câlin second chien pour la
dernière fois et on prend des
médicaments pour en finir avec la vie je
laissais pas qu'une fois j'ai essayé
cette fois c'est cette fois tout je suis
là et fait deux arrêts cardiaques et
3com à bray sur une durée de quatre ans
je m'en suis sorti parce que j'ai une
bonne étoile
c'est pour ça que nous devons parler
maintenant parce que justement j'ai eu
une bonne étoile mais pas tout le monde
peut avoir une bonne étoile